it's not just [ __ ] pool jokes no no
no no no it's a deep critique of the way
we are
hey this is Tommy West hello my name is
cannulas I love to share my opinions and
I'm really quite a nice guy hello my
name is Tyler swerve and I like to
socialize with other skinny ladies like
myself contrary to my name I am NOT a
garment maker hello my mama's are
Hillary Clinton's and I don't have much
a personality but you should vote for me
because I am NOT an [ __ ] okay this
is Donald Trump
hello my name's Donald Trump however
editar like and Muslims like the guise
of so hot I just don't want them in the
country because I'm kind of on a scrub
slaw and I've got like a really big
swamp since no car I've also got an
enormous
I like to collect my money and I'm a
billionaire
I don't like to share it mine haha hello
every name is how you friends come to
Milan to you who are these people
this is Leonardo DiCaprio my name is
Leonardo DiCaprio in am so relieved that
I finally won the Oscar surely I should
have got the big that you ate before
this time this is not fair but I'm glad
anyway and over the third that my movie
the revenant would have done so well I
did Emily sister that's the wrong voice
that's King Julian all right